so I'm going to talk about Voronoi
diagrams this morning and maybe some of
you don't know what those are so I'll
take you through some of the basics and
the sir if there's no more appropriate
place than London to talk about 49
diagrams because one of the firsts
instances of modern epidemiology use the
form of voronoi diagram to look at the
cholera outbreak in Soho 150 years ago
and so this is a map of Soho back back
in the day and I've overlaid blue dots
onto the locations where there were
water pumps so people will go there to
get there to get the water they needed
and then the black bars that are shown
on these maps those are fatalities so
people died in the residences at those
locations and so some of these locations
that have a lot of black bars as a lot
of fatalities there and less fatalities
that the locations that have sort of
smaller bar chart at that particular
location so what jon snow did is he
actually determined how long it would
take for someone to walk to one of these
water pumps and then drew manually drew
this region here you can see around that
central water pump and this is on Broad
Street which is now i think is broadwick
street and determined that most so most
of the people that were most of the
residences that that had people dying
were closest to that particular water so
this is actually a sort of crude example
of a voronoi diagram but a very useful
example of its application in in modern
epidemiology so most of those people
were getting their contaminated water
from that particular pump and just as a
sort of fundamental concept what you
want to do is with one eye diagrams is
to identify the points in space so in
this case is just the planar XY
Cartesian space that are closest to a
given pump or a given generator so we
use the term generator in the field to
refer to an original data point in the
data set but this is not so that the
region that Jon Snow drew manually
doesn't look like a voronoi region does
in most of the modern diagram that
you'll see that's because his is a
walking time based foreign a diagram
and most of the void 0 grams that we
make now are Euclidean distance based so
those will be truly convex of one a
region so I'll tell you little bit more
about that later so Python actually this
wasn't the case a few years ago but now
scipy this is a popular scientific
python library actually has some great
utilities for doing warning diagrams and
some other computational geometry
techniques regular the box so there's
this this is set of data since the the
data from hundred and fifty years ago
but curated for data data journalism so
there was an article in The Guardian a
few years ago and there's a an academics
blog web of Muslims blog at university
of southampton provided the the raw data
to work with this in 2015 so I just
thought I'd create a national voronoi
diagram overlaid on so this was those
black bars in the maps are not being
shown as red dots use radii are
proportional to the number of death of
those residences this is the actual
voronoi diagram so now you can see the
the convex cell and the map here so
everything within that convex cell right
here is closer to the pump on Broad
Street but you can see that there you
know you can see that our residences
with mortalities that are that could
actually go to a pump that's somewhere
else and so there was actually a bit of
journalism involved so Jon Snow had
found out that there was a lot of
anecdotal evidence for people those
locations preferring the water from the
infected pump for whatever reason they
thought it would tasted better that kind
of thing I'm site explains that
particular at least most of the outlier
layer data sets in that particular
diagram but yes so there's this scipy
dot spatial data for annoy and that
actually didn't exist when I first
started working on this a few years ago
you just feed in your your pump
coordinate so the blue dot so just feed
in those coordinates as a numpy array
and then there's actually no there's
actually a built-in plotting function so
you'd even have to do too much work you
just takes I heat at spatial dot voronoi
plot 2d and you feel in the Voronoi
instance object that you created and and
that'll produce apply for you so it's
quite quite convenient now to produce
simple planar of 10 grams and 2d
creation space look for a map
for example and so this is just one
possible application of wiring diagrams
you can also imagine things like looking
at cell phone tower coverage or in
marketing if you want to know which
which stores are closest to where people
are there's all kinds of applications
for Voronoi diagrams in the plane and
this is just one particularly compelling
example because it involves sort of
public health on a large scale and so
cleaner foreign diagrams have been
studied for for quite a long time in
computational geometry in general is
quite young so the nineteen early 1970s
is pretty much when it started so very
early on there was already an
established algorithm because divide and
conquer algorithm which is the this is
still the optimal performance this
notation means that the time complexity
how long it takes to run this algorithm
where n is the number of input data
points in that particular case n would
be the number of those those blue pumps
so this is the so the upper time limit
this log linear time slower would be
this quadratic incremental incremental
algorithm was discovered a few years
later there's also this quad edge data
structure algorithm which I don't know
much about and the famous fortune a
sweep line algorithm so Steve fortune
was working for Bell Labs at the time I
think I mean II came up with a great
algorithm really efficient algorithm
which actually basically just sweeps a
line across from left to right and it
produces the Voronoi diagram on the left
side and then it still has to produce so
it's sort of progressively producing
delorean diagram as it moves from from
left to right across but it turns out
actually that this is one thing that I
found working with different Warren
diagrams is that sometimes the most
efficient implementation isn't the one
that becomes the most popular so it
might be slower but if it's easier to
implement that's a really important
thing so it turns out this incremental
algorithm the quadratic one so it as you
have a quadratic time complexity if
there's a lot of data it can be quite
slow but because it's easy to implement
it's become one of the most popular
implementations even though it's a
little bit slower so sigh he uses the
queue hall library this is a popular
computational geometry library behind
the scenes and it does say that in the
documentation so if you look in the in
the notes so middle say that it uses the
queue whole library and it says a
computer for any diagram via the de
l'année triangulation which is the
mathematical do love the Voronoi diagram
and if you don't know what that means
I'm going to tell you
so don't worry too much with that so one
there's just one or two concepts in
computational geometry that I should go
through before I get good on to the
spherical Voronoi diagrams that I've
been working with one of these concepts
is the convex hull so if we just jump
right to this the picture here of what
the convex hull is in two dimensions if
you think of a for example a wooden
board with with nails placed in it so
each nail is representing one of these
data points when these blue dots if you
took an elastic band and wrapped it
around that set of nails that would be a
sort of visual demonstration of the
convex hull now humans we're actually
pretty good you can actually probably
just by I pick out the points that are
forming the outer boundary of this of
this structure this conduct this convex
hull but computers aren't so good at
that and as you go up to thousands and
thousands of points even for the human
eye become quite difficult to identify
the convex hull so there are algorithms
for doing this once again one of the
slower algorithms the incremental
algorithm I think this was actually
published in 1972 and it was the first
computational geometry paper ever
apparently so so this is a quadratic
time complexity in both two and three
dimensions but it's it's often infinite
just because it's simpler than some of
the others and again log-linear these
are the most efficient algorithms
especially this gift wrapping of them
which is kind of interesting because it
it's time performance actually depends
on the number of points in the hall so
here there's actually points that are
internal and then points that we see on
the halls for the right on the edge
there so if all of this if all the
points in ideas that are on the hall
then this for algorithm is actually
slower so its output sensitive in terms
of its performance which is just
something I hadn't I hadn't seen before
but in any case incremental it seems to
be implemented most often I haven't I
haven't checked the what's going on with
the Q Hall python implementation but
because it allows you to add additional
points after you've done the initial
calculation I suspect it has to be the
incremental algorithm which is quite
tolerant for adding an additional point
after you've done the initial initial
calculation but as with Warner diagrams
it's now quite easy to do convex hull
calculations in Python again using the
popular scipy library side p dot spatial
convex hull and there's also a
convenience plotting function so you
just take the the whole logic that you
got by calling the
this IP convex hull on your original
data points then just plot it in 2d you
don't have to write the plotting code
you get a nice plot of a nice platter of
that so that's quite convenient 3d hulls
it's the same sort of concept so you
have a hero just taken a random set of
3d points you have to do the plotting
yourself but it's not it's not too big
of a deal and here instead of it being
like an elastic band around a planar set
of points is more like sort of like a
plastic bag around points in
three-dimensional space what wraps right
tightly around them and you have these
faces or these facets that form sort of
faces of the polygon that surrounds
those points in three-dimensional space
so another really important concept in
this is directly related to varna
diagrams is the concept of
triangulations and if you you can
actually define triangulations without
using the word triangle so it's
basically just the maximum number of
edges that connect the data points in
your riginal data set that don't cross
so non intersecting edges so it's really
really this really simple definition
that's actually amazing there's a lot
that we don't know about triangulations
even if planar points in in
two-dimensional space so here T is just
the total number of triangles k is the
number of interior points so the points
that are not on that convex hull and h
is the number of points it up in the
comics Hall so you can see that for a
given a given set of points t the number
of triangles in a planar triangulation
is always fixed it's always the same
number of triangles however we don't we
don't actually have a great way to
figure out the number of just like how
many different triangulations with that
same number of triangles exist so just
recently six years ago we found out that
30 to the power of the number of data
points is the maximum number of triangle
ations that's a lot of triangulations so
the this is still a very nascent field
even though it seems like a really
simple concept you're just connecting
these points in a plane so what's really
interesting from the standpoint of what
I do and for what people working on
Voronoi diagrams is this idea of the
Jelani triangulation this is considered
it's considered and this is the
technical term it's considered the
fattest triangulation so you basically
take the triangles and take the
triangulation that avoids really skinny
triangles so like from a programming
standpoint you do like a lexicographic
comparison so you take all
the angles so if you go through each of
these triangles take all of their angles
so just one flat list of all of those
angles then you can pay so if you
compare two different triangle ations
for those two flat lists the first one
that has it has an angle that's smaller
than the other is considered the
skinnier triangulation so the fatter
triangulation avoids really small angles
at the start of that list that in other
words it avoids really skinny triangles
and that's actually like the formal
nomenclature for this sort of thing and
you can actually build different
triangulations just using edge flipping
so if you imagine if just take this edge
right here and then erase it and draw it
from this vertex to this vertex that
would be an illegal at you say it's an
illegal edge because it generates a
really skinny triangle if you met in the
triangle form between this vertex and
this vertex it's really skinny triangle
and what the computer would do is just
actually do that lexicographic
comparison where you have the really
skinny angles here and here and it would
reject that as not being the de l'année
triangulation and again sigh he provides
a really useful de l'année class object
and you can just just feed that in
you'll get the doll any triangulation
for your 2d point set right away that's
quite useful another definition of the
donate regulation which is really really
useful for voronoi purposes is that it
always excludes the original data points
from the circumcircle so if you take any
given triangle like this one here this
big one at the edge here and draw a
circle that has its its odor line going
through those three points none of the
original data points will actually be
found in in a given circle so it's a bit
hard to tell in the metal here because
it's so dense but you can see here that
there's no original data points that
actually falling within the circle there
just on the edge that's also part of the
definition an alternative definition of
these Deline triangulations from a
practical standpoint denying
translations are considered the best way
to do terrestrial reconstruction so if
you want to have hope these fancy maps
of the earth's surface elevation is only
measured at certain points and you went
sort of triangulate that to make a nice
smooth
blind translations are considered the
best way to do that there's also these
minimum weight triangulations which are
use if you were building like a network
of actual physical wires connecting
nodes if you want to reduce the amount
of wire because that wiring is expensive
for example there's a type of
triangulation that can be used to tell
you which connections to make to reduce
the amount of wire involved there so
that's that can actually be quite useful
as well but for my purposes so it's
really interesting is that because the
Deline triangle ation is the
mathematical do love the Borneo diagram
you can actually connect the Centers of
those circumcised so again these are the
the circles that you draw through the
triangles on the doling triangulation if
you connect all of those together you
get the Voronoi diagram which is really
quite useful so they're connected and
really really deep and interesting ways
and I also turns out that the de la was
for annoys PhD students many many years
ago at key of university so also
connected in that way and the convex
hull is also beautifully connected to
the Delaney triangulations and the
Voronoi diagrams I won't see too too
much about that but it will come up in
the spherical voronoi algorithm and I I
go through so before I sort of start
going through the algorithm that that
that I that I've used for the Python
implementation of spherical voronoi
analysis I decided motivate it with with
what I use it for and what what other
people could and do use it for so I'm a
computational virologist so I build a
models of viruses not computer viruses
but viruses that make people sick so
this is a model of influenza a virus so
it has these spike proteins the orange
ones these are actually the
hemagglutinin protein so those latch on
to sugars and a respiratory tract so
someone coughs or sneezes that's how it
sort of attaches into our respiratory
tracts and infects us I might put it in
a water droplet and it sort of wiggles
and jiggles as I do these simulations
and I could use Python to parse that
that motion over time to try to gain
biophysical insights into this into this
pathogen so this is just a snapshot of a
voronoi diagram on the sphere these sort
of larger yellow points or for these
large proteins this is a really zoomed
in region so it looks almost planar
because of zoomed right in to the
surface and here you can actually see
the individual voronoi cells yellow is
that is the protein
Green is actually cholesterol so so it
turns out that flu actually takes a lot
of cholesterol from our bodies when I
buds off provide sort of a structural
rigidity but ok that's what I do but
probably a lot of you aren't doing that
from day to day but there are actually a
lot of other potential uses for
spherical Voronoi diagrams it turns out
so Jason Davies said it may be something
you might even know him he's in London
he's a I think he's a data science
consultant and I i think a year to after
i started doing spherical annoy research
he wrote with seems to get javascript
implementation of spherical Vorian
diagrams so you can actually go on and
sort of interact with the diagram you
can't provide input data and get get
output with like the the actual stroke
of 10 diagrams you can do calculations
with it it seems the closed source but
nonetheless it sort of it shows you this
is this is our planet with with the all
of the airports in forming the the
initial generator points in a voronoi
diagram so you can imagine applications
like search and rescue so what's the
closest airport to a grid in a search
and rescue situation livorno voronoi
diagram provide a really convenient way
to access that information if you're
living in a country that sort of has
regular problems with sort of Russian
aircraft infiltrating airspace you want
to know what's the closest airbase to
dispatch a jet which is probably really
expensive thing to do with taxpayer
money you might wanna have a spherical
voronoi diagram of the surface of the
earth for that purpose global
epidemiology so looking at disease
outbreaks telecommunication so network
coverage and that kind of thing all
kinds of potential applications probably
many that I haven't thought of first
sphere achill vorna diagrams so when I
was looking to do this in Python because
there's a paucity of open source
resources for doing spherical warning
diagrams I looked at the primary
literature I'm an academic so that's
sort of my intuition I actually didn't
know about this older paper so I went
straight to a more recent paper which
used the stereographic projection so
that's it basically you you you project
the coordinates from the sphere onto a
plane and then you do a planar of Warner
diagram any project Mac up and then you
do some more work and you project it
back down so you do two planar of 10
diagrams I spent a few months probably
way too much time on that and just I did
not have any success
it turns out that the so that again as
with the planar case the the maximal if
performance is log-linear but I just had
a lot of trouble looking at the the
primary literature and so I went to the
internet which is I guess so the last
resorts but also potentially the most
useful resource and so Stack Overflow
just some ones who have innocently made
this comment and then I also found that
there's a close source in this wolfram
mathematica applets where you can
actually you can click on a sphere and
it sort of made me feel kind of bad
because there's just you know sort of a
child like exercise and I just explained
how it works but you know I thought we
needed an open source implementation
regardless and also because this again
it's just a sort of an online thing
where you can click on it but but not
really interact with in a meaningful way
where you put in your data set and you
get out your voronoi diagram then you
calculate for example the areas of the
different regions and that's or that you
want something that's malleable that you
can work with with your own data do data
munging with it but certainly the
internet played a big role in instead of
suggesting that if you compute the
convex hull on a sphere on a perfect
sphere that's equivalent to the delaney
triangulation and then if you take the
normals to the faces of the convex hull
on the surface of the sphere you get the
Voronoi vertices that's a much much
easier algorithm then than any of these
papers have implemented so I thought I
would try that so that forms the basis
of the the implementation which is open
source i just put it up on github a few
months ago it's also i like to think
it's well-documented i spent a fair bit
of time writing the dock strings and
describing what it does there's also
some detailed notes section which I've
clipped out here which talks about some
of the limitations and also tell you
about some limitations and some of the
area's REM actually I'm hoping to get
some maybe some advice on some of the
weaknesses of the algorithm and the
problems with the code there's also an
example here which I think you can
probably copy and paste into a you know
and I Python notebook and it should work
right away you can see the result for
for a living 1,000 point random data set
looks quite reasonable so you can see
the sort of the bore and I cells in the
surface of a sphere so is quite
with the initial this with the initial
outcome of the the code so I want to go
through step-by-step there are too many
steps to this algorithm but just just to
show you how I did it I think I've taken
a few liberties with with the sort of
the indentation so I know python of
course obviously depends strong
indentation for for clarity but here
just for the person the presentation
I've made a few adjustments just for
just like it fit it fit it all together
so basically I just took a thousand
random points on a sphere sphere with a
radius of 1 this is a function in the
open source code that but I have it
turns out that generating random points
on a sphere is actually its own field of
mathematics I probably still haven't
done it perfectly but if you tried to it
naively it turns out that almost all the
points end up on the poles which is
really really annoying so you think I've
almost got it right but I all I wanted
to do was just pin down they also pin
down the rent so I've use a random see
that pin down because it turns out
there's actually pathological input so
if you have points that are co circular
I think that's pathological see the head
you have to have certain requirements on
the data input so real data is often
okay but if you just start working with
random data you can get and end up with
some pretty pathological obviously can
imagine like two points or practically
on top of each other that's going to
cause like floating point problems when
you're doing calculations so thanks to
the internet we know the de l'année
triangulation is equivalent to the
convex hull so we can use the built-in
convex hull on the three-dimensional
points on the surface of the sphere here
I'm just working with random coordinates
could probably get rid of this for loop
so just feel free forgive me for that
the code still and it's sort of early
conceptual stages where you used to work
with for loops then get rid of them when
you optimize later on but basically just
going through all of the the triangles
and not in in the convex hull and just
collecting those points into an array
which basically has n triangles which
are in three dimensional space so it has
a three ver Texas with with their x y&z
coordinates so generators the original
data points are in blue and then the
triangulation the edges that connects
those points the delight regulation is
shown in in red now this with this big
wall of code is basically just
it's basically is cooking the normals so
the lines that go from the sort of the
center of the sphere through the the
triangles in the doling triangulation
and those end up being the Voronoi
vertices so it's kind of painful how
close we are to the solution already so
we have our original data points in blue
and the vertices the points that are
deformed the Voronoi diagram that we
want in green now here's where I really
actually have a lot of problems so we're
really close to the answer but the
challenge is associating the Voronoi
vertices so the points in green with the
data points that they're supposed to
surround and also basically we have to
order the polygon vertices that are in
really close proximity that can be a
little bit tricky you'll see that I had
some problems with missing vertices I'm
just wondering if there's a better way
to do it and then then I've chosen to do
it so you keep that in mind as we go
through the small number of steps that
are involved so the way I ended up doing
it was basically to take we know that
each for my vertex is equidistant to at
least three of the original generator
points so you can see basically one of
these volunteer vertices Green is I
creative sent to three points so it's
shown for this is shown over to random
points I've taken out of the code here
so this is the result of the code so the
code is basically generates a distance
matrix up here using sigh piece see
distance method and then purchase that
distance matrix to figure out which are
the closest original data points to give
them four new vertex and then make sure
that there's at least three of those as
an assertion here because if it doesn't
then there's something wrong and then we
know which original data points are
closest to a voronoi for attacks but we
actually want to know is which warner vs
should surround a given generator and so
this is done using Remo hedgers
collections module two to speed things
up a little bit and so basically you can
see there's at least one case here were
actually works quite well so we've
connected the dots the vertices quite
nicely around original data point one
case it looks like it's a terrible
situation because the generator is
nowhere near the the polygon that's
supposed to surround it
and in one case it looks like this is
salvageable with just the the vertices
haven't been ordered properly yet so
that's something that we can deal with
the next step of the process to this is
no this is this is just for the
spherical case so in the planar case it
that shouldn't shouldn't occur where you
have a this shouldn't happen in the
spherical case either but it's happening
with my particular equation y there's no
no I'm certainly concerned as to why
that why that happens yeah there's a
question there too yeah I tried both
yeah so it turns out the cord length
which which actually goes through the
the sphere is directly related to the
arc length anyway so I didn't find any
difference because you just plug it into
equation and it just it works out to
being the same effect actually and then
finally I so I can sort you could this
various ways to sort the vertices of the
polygon and so we see we see here that
for this pathological case on the right
that was actually sorted out so now this
is a nice convex polygon but for the
case on the left although we have a
convex polygon the generator is not
contained within it so that's that's an
issue nonetheless overall the diagram
doesn't look too too bad more than
ninety ninety-five percent of the
surface area is reconstituted so if you
take all of these polygons areas that
sell them together that adds up to
roughly what you'd expect for the
service area of a sphere of that radius
we do have these issues and if you look
at example result so this is an actual
result we can see this in this little
blank spaces so Voronoi diagrams
definitely should not have these blank
spaces that's why it looks fairly minor
in that case if i take a more
pathological case you can see that the
blank spaces are a little bit bigger
that's a bit of an issue i've also had
some problems so if you want to
calculate the surface area of these
polygons so if you just assume that
they're planar that's fine that works
reasonably well if you want to actually
calculate because these are actually
curved polygons the surface of a sphere
if you want to deal with these these
angles on the surface of the sphere it
actually seems to be quite unstable to
sort of floating-point issues so people
have suggestions the certain equations
for dealing with this but they still
seem to be sensitive to issues if the
points are close enough together
so just to sort of small conclusions so
ultimately in a fairly small number of
steps we I have the the Voronoi wrote
okies the sworn I vertices on the
surface of the sphere and the challenge
seems to just needed to take that data
so we almost have the answer we just
need to know how to connect the answers
to form the diagram and maybe someday
Sirico voronoi will be possible in scipy
that's based on but if people think
that's useful so I have to say well it's
time um the chapstick door finished
early that's why her driving um any
questions for Tyler apparently diagrams
yeah thank you for the nice presentation
I just wanted to make a comment for
generally generating the dots near the
poles hmm so I think that the
distribution when you generated theta
angle you have it has to be uniform not
in Peter but inside theta and you'll get
a uniform distribution over the t tengo
we're talking about putting the points
nicely over this fear yeah there's a few
papers I've seen about it yes if it's
uniform in theta then because sine is
changing rapidly there was higher values
closer to 0 you have much more values
closer to 90 degrees records why you get
the polar advisors have to take a
transformation sine theta and take the
distribution of sine theta and then so
it has to be uniform distribution or
sine theta you can generate random
number between 0 and 1
what you're gonna do you have addition
to the answer so do you want to generate
one point on the sphere you have a
number of damage to the atomic alarm
system and any sonically generating
calcium THX you get an example to run
you metal a panacea Jamie's field its
run away it's pretty good reference 13
good trick yeah I have a question but so
I work in I done a lot of work with lung
damage and cells often form what looked
like for any diagrams so does any have
building generating very diagrams isn't
one way of going do you have our
equations for going backwards analyzing
very diagrams and seeing how they change
over time it's certainly be the kind of
thing where you it's very hard to do
quantitative analysis of tissue damage
but invariably its core this cells and a
given system died so analysis a parade
diagram to be quite useful for being
able to analyze how much damage is being
done to give in tissue is that something
that's very diagrams tackle so I mean my
dear there's our time series based so I
basically calculate the Voronoi diagram
each time point so the viruses viruses
moving around in water so i can actually
calculate the size of a given bore and i
sell over time so i basically traveling
over time so that's one way to look at
sort of how it's changing over time but
yeah I think you'll always have the same
number of voronoi cells because you have
the same number of generators so that's
gonna remain constant but you could
certainly look at the fluctuation in in
the amount of area occupied by given a
given generator which is the size of its
polygons and surface actually I don't
know from my algorithm my first priority
is to make it work and then I'll start
worrying about the time complexity yeah
I was just wondering yeah roughly what
kind of dogs you guys it's fast enough
for my purposes but yeah and that's
we've got agonizing
yeah maybe maybe 40,000 at the most but
but yeah it hasn't been a bottleneck
yeah yeah I've hand I'm not sure but it
doesn't take two it hasn't been
something that I've noticed sinuous in
terms of the early so I have no much
benchmarking yeah you Cecilia first
priorities at a naked work so um but you
know that this closed-off implementation
you mentioned at the beginning that this
has the same problem no I'm not aware of
this issue any of the closed source of
limitations there's one on Wolfram and
then there's the one in other one of the
JavaScript so but I just I don't have
enough information I can zoom in and I
can't I can't pull out the data and
actually look at it in detail but I
suspected that they don't have that
issue there are several papers in the
primary literature so maybe trying a
different algorithm would work would
work better but some do you think the
problem is somehow the is it's more like
a counting problem that there's in the
second the algorithm what do you think
that this is a conceptual problem or to
do this in theory maybe a little bit of
both but but I think it's probably
primarily just the coding just going
from we already have the Voronoi
vertices so just going from that
information you should be able to just
sort of juice a distance do the distance
matrix and rebuild the Voronoi diagram
that's my general feeling and I just for
some reason that's not working and I'm
not sure I'm not sure why so maybe maybe
there's something really simple that
someone could just point out and I've
screwed up somewhere I hope that's the
case I do hope that's the case but I'm
found that's all
yeah you're just three dimensional
convex hull and then that forms the data
set the same data structure as the de
l'année triangulation is really good
drink here as well which you might find
is not easier so if you take your sphere
and then you add the center point and
then you build a 3 triangle ation Des
Moines regulation again then you have a
set of simplices and all of them have
the center point if is not generate now
for each if you look outside faces of
those sympathies and each of those will
be a face and the Des Moines translation
on this bed then you take the
circumcenter of those simply synthesis
and then you could get onto the sphere
like your Giovanni vertices and then if
you get to right around each point of
the boy electra as its only translation
then you will get the sympathies you
just have to seduce circulate around I
can explain this entry in 42 if you like
that them yeah I definitely interested
in and i'll turn it like an alternative
construction strategy I'm so if you know
you are aged workers ego which is the
library Singh that okay no there are
various really a squatter oh yeah you
have any more questions for Tyler before
we break for a small break lovely Tyler
you'll be around all day and tomorrow
and tomorrow lovely time zone or the
weekend do ask your questions do then
otherwise we're gonna break the next
5-10 minutes and then start our next
door so thank you very much thank you